[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning guys I hope you had a nice
breakfast in Xenia
filled up with an original to make this
mental shift and of life NASA coding
guidelines to JavaScript who misses
history started many years ago and this
talk is actually composed of two talks I
was giving the poor the first talk is
about exploring what boundaries of
JavaScript could be and then the second
talk is about why we're not there and
how to get there there how to ensure
more trust into JavaScript my name is
Dennis redden you may find me on the
network as a pixels commander I work in
a company called verax fortress so known
Anna German is my hammer mobile it over
before talking about javascript
guidelines let's talk about the
guidelines for this universe one of the
fundamental
pendings of this universe is attempting
to unification so this universe respects
unification the shape of planets the
laws of physics say constant everywhere
it's all going to be unified in this
universe it's indirectly according to
wikipedia unification is effective
method to decrease diversity and
unification is to place elements in
particular order build a strict system
which is comfortable to use we create
diversity importable to use strict
system yes there are six students of
standardized units in this universe
they're very similar a bit different
very individual but still that tends to
be standardized and then humanity adapt
disease tend into standardization also
every time we start something new we
start on some new fields now
logic filled their industry or whatever
we start with whole variety of possible
solutions
it works for politics for economics for
art for engineering and yeah then we are
going to talk about engineering first of
all as I said in the beginning we do the
whole lot of possible solutions but
generally the best most efficient
survive can you you see a plane in the
background right can you distinguish is
it a Boeing or Airbus maybe someone can
actually me not the balance and this one
is a very similar really only specialist
can distinguish born core Airbus if you
go to the plane you can read somewhere
it's a boiler its Airbus but it was not
like that in the beginning it was a tan
wing explains all rotating wing explains
some crazy constructions the same the
same kind of story we see in a software
development we develop software for 60
years but such a common thing is
defining a UI is not standardized here
it's not tender time yet so it still
looks like early ages of aviation so
let's try to compare early ages of
aviation with our current state or what
we recently had in a front-end developer
and compare solutions front-end
development with the solutions ok
solutions used on the early ages of
aviation so yeah as I said 16 years of
trying to make things tender ties in the
UI development industrious of our
development industry but we still don't
have a standards it reminds me early
ages of aviation and we have this all
variety of solutions for just make human
flight let's try to compare early ages
of aviation to early ages of software
development we have now this is amazing
video technologies what kind of
technology is that Microsoft Silverlight
Adobe flex
it's a good try
it's completely amazing so Nate
the deflesh it's almost did it and I was
pretty pretty closed my favorite it's
even not shooting himself until lag but
just it's a Java applet so yes basically
as I said once we start something we try
all kind of different solutions but then
on the best survive in the same works
for software engineering course for any
kind of engineering so yeah all planets
around the laws of physics are constant
everywhere and all your eyes are going
to be unified and what is going to be
the standard for you is let's guess
let's guess yes I want it you want it
everybody want it it's going to be a web
platform we all believe it that's why
we're here together in this conference
and since I'm a big fan of Aviation once
I try to combine to my passion
especially to JavaScript passion to web
technologies and a patient evaluation
and then I started here I think she also
have you eyes and then information is
standardized very well by itself then
your wife's innovation is going to be
standardized with the standard in the UI
development so why not to build your
aircraft instrument with HTML Javascript
why not okay so there is the motivation
for that there is a motivation in terms
of unification reliability and
accessibility so first of all we live in
the age of drones unmanned drones then
access to a state of a flight mission
where HTTP for example is a pretty good
thing to have
then unification means that we have a
lot of developers developing with
JavaScript and web technologies and it's
not that hard to develop flight
instrument to be honest I mean just
display interfaces and it's a good
unified technology also if you think
about that web platform is amazingly
amazingly reliable the billions of users
daily opens billions of pages
and they constantly contribute to a
safety and reliability of a platform and
also once we have unified technology to
develop instruments we can establish a
components market where across and some
of you can develop our craft instruments
and sell them to by example just yeah
why not
okay once I saw that there is a
motivation let's try to do that it was
not hard to be honest zero reservoir
some coverage but then we ended up by a
real real flight on a real plane it was
a flying about Amsterdam around 1000
meters heat the serial HTML Javascript
sync and we were flying relying on it
sure yeah but maybe it was cool actually
so first of a flight with HTML
Javascript driven instrument but then
okay we did it the considerations
they're subject to consider was of
course reliability of course we need to
if you have problems with your
instrument your topic really vegetation
then memory leaks is a probably the most
obvious thing to take care of because
once you have member leaks you have less
responsive instrument is better even can
make fresh then resources consumption
efficiency also to think about maybe for
this you can use GPU accelerated pass or
alternative rendering methods of WebGL
canvas okay so now you can imagine you
came into your plane you take a place in
airplane and someone says you hey man
flight commander have a JavaScript
driven instrument in his cabin and you
are going to fly it on a Boeing on a
JavaScript driven Boeing is a vet
developer JavaScript developer drop few
lines of code and you are going to five
is that you're going to be scared you're
going to discourage definitely or not
who will fly this plane
oh yeah it was quick I get back yes but
yes let's think why you're not going to
fight this plan it's basically your
perception of yourself your perception
of web development your perception of
JavaScript development it's it's
basically your trust in yourself it's
your trust in the web platform
it's your trust in guidelines in what's
normal for JavaScript of course it's
easy to understand why it happened
because the price the price of mistake
or error it's very cheap in a JavaScript
world you just reload the page
everything starts again you'll safe but
then there are some missions when it's
not like that and that with evolving of
a web platform
javascript language we have more and
more such missions and we need to
rethink our guidelines and we're seeing
what's normal for javascript and that
change the way people perceive Gela
script and how we trust ourselves so we
need more guidelines probably to change
the way what's normal
let's have a look at the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory which is the institution it's
not a kind of branch which works in a
project like curiosity Mars rover right
and the Voyager and the Whizzer is
amazing because it's certainly six years
flying in a deep space without any bugs
can you javascript desert 36 years no
but then we had a similar problem not
statistics year is banned when I used to
work for four years in a unity media on
a project called horizon we had the set
of boxes set of boxes had the operation
Josip during oppression system is a half
million line of codes and the stability
and performance for pretty high
priorities like one month without Reza
it was pretty challenging so we try to
adopt this NASA guidelines it's not it's
not a fish
[Music]
it's not some reach thing it's really
guidelines which GPL use and nothing use
and they're published online you can
check them so yeah that's right
rule number one no function should be
longer than what we can be can be
printed on a sheet of paper it comes
from all times
you may seen this photo Margaret
Hamilton with the the author of Apollo
mission source code staying with the
source code basically and then it's easy
to understand why they were talking
about sheets of papers at time but now
we can rephrase it do one thing in one
function you do one thing then it means
higher readability you are comparing to
what you have right and all together you
can compose your functions or factory
functions better yeah very composability
l sir then yeah do on same place if you
don't do it that it's obvious it's
really easy to adopt this rule Earl
number to restrict alcohol to very
simple control flow constructs do not
use go-to statements and Rick or
indirect recursion okay go to it's easy
to understand but what about recursion
how can we live without recursion and
why not so want to be so actually is
there reason pizzetta's that matter
relies on aesthetic analogies a lot and
they won't call to be predictable first
of all predictable then they use static
analysis for that so for us it sounds
like Earl number two predictability if
you want to write reliable code drop the
right cool them and then serve to write
predictable code defined coding
standards and follow it you static
analogies it's very important now it's
really a flourishing part of JavaScript
if you don't use static analogies
because you should sir you static
analysis to support standard and reduce
chance for defect use es leans with
whole lot of plugins and presses and of
course air be air BnB press it is a good
place to start and there is a whole lot
of plugins we'll go through some of them
during this presentation but there is a
lot of nice things happening to increase
the quality of your code
and supports a standard is established
collect metrics because you need to
track how things are going in your
codebase and analyze types good good
tools for analyzing types now rule
number three do not use memory dynamic
memory allocation after initialization
so okay it's really realized for
JavaScript land because JavaScript have
dynamic memory allocation by default and
then memory is managed by JavaScript by
garbage collection and there's a problem
because we got too relaxed about that
and many developers is don't respect all
this Ram Singh so rule numbers really
respect Graham because garbage
collection might become your enemy I
will not run into details how because I
hazards headless links but then I don't
think I have enough of time I hope
everybody knows why garbage collection
is bad and how to how basically work
with memory leaks and how to or someone
wants to look how timeline works now ok
then yes measure with depth rule
timeline how much memory are going to
use then compare the state of your
application compare the snapshots of
your application to see where our memory
leaks or the state of your system of
your memory then yeah just take care of
the memory manager were able to is read
spec declares variables at the top of
the scope to increase their visibility
you see a flint versus on top so yeah
just to have one place to keep your
variables sort them for predictability
much for memory leaks clean listeners
and variables will not needed anymore
use easily know you unused verse which
is very important and many people use
but if you don't use it Linda's very
important to start is that so so we
should JavaScript the static memory
allocation mode with object pooling I
think some of them know that there is
kind an option to have less memory
allocation during runtime by using
object pooling so how it looks like you
create some set of objects initially
when your application start for example
you create
256 objects
and you have a function to get object
from pool and then to put it back
release object then all this year it
uses 256 object then it's a less memory
allocation of course it's not static
right
but please you try you can reserve a
rule number for all loops must have a
big set upper bound
it also comes from NASA tend to have a
good static analysis but I don't think
we should follow this rule okay we would
like to have recursion steel and you'd
like to be flexible because we would
like to be efficient first of all that
yeah there is a rule number for Vanessa
rule number 5 the essential assertion
density of the code should average the
minimum of two assertions function two
assertion assertion is not a unit test
the second assumption running in the
runtime and it checks is there the state
of application matches given so rule
number five loss means sounds like test
well write higher test density is less
defects you get a sure minimal amount of
tests to per function that's right
what's fun demolishing system state
during runtime generate and handle
errors in case of critical situations
measure coverage but be aware 100
coverage doesn't necessarily mean you
have well tested code because coverage
is a quantitative not qualitative
metrics then roll number six data
objects must be declared at the smallest
possible level of scope that's basically
all about mutable shared State and many
of us most of us face this problem there
are good tools now in JavaScript world
to solve this problem then things like
Redux all this what you need Direction
flows and so on but then yeah anyway
it's really nice to see that there is
good matches between NASA needs not
subproblems and our problems so and we
already have some solutions for them
yeah it's also good to es lien plugins
therefore checking a pureness was
developed by a Roman Melnick and works
pretty well I mean for example you can
test your reducers for a pureness and
add some safety to their team and
something to standards rule number seven
this rule NASA say they break the most
often it basically says the return value
of non-void functions must be checked by
each Colin function so you call function
then you immediately check is it correct
response from it not then NASA often
break it I don't think we are going to
use it as well so rule number seven will
skip a rule number eight the use of
preprocessor must be limited to the
inclusion of piller files and simple
macro definitions right it references
the C preprocessor we have a lot of
pre-processing right now in JavaScript
also but actually there are two problems
with that so the first problem is
preferred setting with transpiling is
that you don't own the code you execute
anymore the browser executes so it's
pretty it's pretty reliable nowadays but
still it should keep in mind that the
code you write is not equality execute
and the result surprises that price in
terms of performance as the reson
project which compared performance of
six features compare intro translation
engines sometimes it's identical a few
months ago year ago it was very
different I mean now there are a lot of
green fields but still some yellow stuff
means three times lower two times slower
yeah translation have a price and you
should be aware of Z also there is the
cost for bundling bonding and
transpiling and yes there is a table
with differences of different bundlers
and the difference sometimes 10 15 20
percent so it's remarkable they even may
change the bundling system because of Z
but I don't think you'll do
Earl number nine the use of pointers
should be restricted especially no more
than one level of the reference is
allowed function pointers are not
permitted okay it's hard to use for
JavaScript because every single object
does n we have a lot of pointers but yes
still can be used because of two in two
ways so one of them is called change so
if you use large coal chains it's
basically also level of the reference
and as they say now we had less
performance because every coal by the
chain takes some time Susanne it
decreases performance also it's all
about the law of the Metra so loose
coupling so loose companies just
textural pattern it's not about
JavaScript or C or so yeah if you have a
dog
it's a classic example if you have a dog
you don't say dog body legs run but then
you just say dog run and dog knows how
to run by legs atone or whatever depends
on its own state so loose coupling and
it's more called cold chains Earl number
10 all code must be compiled from the
first day of development result compiler
warnings enabled well it is basically
the most important one it's basically
the way you perceive your processes the
way you perceive your codebase and just
let's name it keep it green if it drain
from the first day of development and
perceived your project is something
serious from the first day of
development but I know some of you
already start with different approach so
you are already read so what do we
already [ __ ] up what what what to do
if you already read to just don't panic
don't panic
simply prioritize your models those
tests implement standards implement
stuff we were talking about it was a
just ten rules of NASA that
chance is the last one this sure but
then by trying adopting them and more
sinks more slim plugins by establishing
standards by making your codebase better
we're improving the process we can make
this shift which currently do not allow
you to fly on a JavaScript driven
airplane we can make this change and to
perceive ourselves differently
the perceive ourselves like developers
who produce first-class code to produce
the same kind of code people in NASA and
GPL produce and as same if it goes this
way if you constantly improve our code
analysis tools our process and our
perception of web development I'll trust
in ourselves one day we are going to
deserve one day we are going to be on
airplanes but I know some people already
on airplanes there are people using a
node.js on Boeing's it's not used for a
Excel autopilot or whatever but they
standardized some impaired models it's
KLM and Netherlands we standardize some
impaired models to put an Iraq and a
buoyant an Airbus so they really fly it
with node.js nowadays KLM and it works
it's not connected to flight system but
there is they use it for media but it
was still a long way to standardize the
load of NPM and ogs models will set but
they did it in JavaScript is already
unburn can Airbus so yeah
let's try and yeah why not see for
example also Netherlands there are
companies building a ship instrument
with JavaScript if ships are there
explains as they're what stops us only
trust in ourselves only our perception
of web development our perception of
JavaScript that's it thank you
[Applause]